yeah welcome to this video playing the Z
integrator okay I forgot who that is or
no it doesn't have a name there okay so
let's be in solid here i have a bad
score against this person really bad one
win three losses so we get into a okay
to a wretched opening could have been a
catalan but it's a ratty opening now an
a5 is an interesting way to play on the
queenside okay what now really have
forgotten how this is played I go see
six years that c6 in order to threaten
deform but then he has defined a five is
not quite clear what a 5 has it done
deef en D for 9b five looks wrong though
ok I'm going to play that move
that was my idea Bishop to a 6 putting
some pressure on the c4 porn those ideas
with Bishop 86 are pretty common in the
catalan catalan closed variation here
but a difference is that in this
particular case i have a five plate yeah
i was thinking be five now is that crazy
let's see
I'm pre-move buttock area it's not very
likely moves he takes me 5 mm I don't
know maybe but it looks looks a bit
strange I expect if I yes so just if i
drop back I guess
hmm I don't think that's too bad i mean
i have Knight b6 coming with a possible
increase their of pressure on that point
on c4 it's not bad yeah getting out of
that diagonal so I'm going to take play
Knight b6 right or if i do that you
might please see you see five let's not
let's not bad though see 594 I can play
and I also i didn't see much of time
terms of an alternative pawn takes e4
maybe also interesting clearing the d5
square but yeah okay let's just play 9
p-6 cm and jump into that we can square
at least my bishop make some somewhat
more active impression then it often
does in the in the Catalan okay right
here is he going nighty for here maybe
set an idea of this move 94 for yeah
maybe 94 for possibly 96 okay let's
let's go back and avoid that possibility
all together
anyway have to do that at a five pound
still calls for some concern it's a
little bit weak
and my pawns are still a bit weaker than
whites especially this a 5 and c6 is
also currently not under pressure but it
can happen that it becomes a target
later
yeah it wants to move the night and then
but maybe I can play it with Bishop to
d8 which is not a very attractive
looking move admittedly but the bishop
has a function then at least protecting
the a5 witness it's not very quick
though so I'm ahead on the clock okay if
I take it he will take with the pawn
probably awkward but here I can go back
to see for him I like that 94 ideas not
in chandler position again because of
Bishop b5 and maybe still queer five
then but okay it didn't happen didn't
happen you went to e3
so what exactly night a form I don't
know ok I'm going to protect this pawn
again maybe try to move that rook as I
need to the night Stewie form using the
unprotected State of the bishop ok
ok I've got it covered at the moment how
to flame I wonder if ff6 looks very
loose his pieces will easily switch to
the other side of the board I think I
can go back he actually now which is
admittedly not doing that much and that
between night b2e I aya you have to
blunder twist to a one mover in this
position sick sick I'm defending that I
think quite okay I don't think there was
and there was simply nothing going on
and not blunder that that porn there in
a one move him great and it's
immediately unplayable the put I'm
morning
amazing three totally unplayable a c6 is
collapsing as well my knight never gets
to any decent square
can you even take a five if he if he
likes but I couldn't really attend to
that and I'm blonde room c 6 what a mess
there that was nothing going on and and
then this is stupid that's side
immediately after i move it of course
that sets the typical way it happens
check okay but he has got Queenie eight
mate it didn't see 93 and absolutely not
but it's got lucky in that position that
it's got Queenie eight okay so okay
black resins stupid very stupid very
stupid nose I mean of course I'm
somewhat worse here all all that all
that time but I think I think I defended
okay and ultimately nothing was going on
here this absolutely nothing but this is
just totally totally your take yeah I
mean night between so it immediately as
usual now I can just play whatever I am
something and not that it's not
blundering sorry this is something like
this I'm just staying by Bishop there is
okay it takes a five white what can can
try to improve their but I'm quite okay
there nothing nothing really wrong with
it
now an interesting moment maybe is here
where I can take what the pawn that was
something that I was briefly thinking
about but not not long the good idea or
the good point of it is that night here
935 isn't it as a possibility yes this
kind of idea though because he also
gained the e4 square Knight f3 94
switching over many pieces to the king
it was an interesting alternative
probably a bit better hear this I'm
slideshows but stumbling into 92 is just
frustrating okay thanks for watching